okay sienna's calling oh no ah
i pick up i pick up wait where's my
discord
eric how's it going
good good how's it going
good we were just having like some
dilemma what do i call you do i call you
david or korean american chess noob or
noob oh okay
yeah no david david is perfect i think a
lot of people
some people call me like korean or kucn
but uh yeah david is good
that's my name yeah every time i see you
in chat i either abbreviate or
go a full length with all the syllables
yeah thanks for asking eric that's
that's so kind of you yeah
and i guess the first thing to note when
uh i assuming you're starting with
knight f6 which is probably like the
most flexible move
um
white can play c4
or white can play bishop f4 or knight f3
these are like the common alternatives
or even bishop g5
so like already
with white second move there's a bunch
of different ways
for the position to kind of branch out
um
most commonly you'll run into
c4
and bishop f4
i guess knight of three is also like
mixed in there like knight three could
go to london or queen's gambit like
there's different trans positions too
um
but you like as black i guess you have
to distinguish between when white's
going for c4 and when white's going for
a london setup
um so you're gonna have to like treat
this as a perhaps a few different
openings
um yeah actually
when white play c4
i'll just
give you a list of the options which i
think would be
most aligned with your style
of course if you wanted to we could dig
in into c5 more
um and try and just make your current
repertoire
i guess more robust and less improvised
the other options um if you want to try
and be aggressive
one of my favorite gambits of all time
is budapest with e5
which on the surface if you haven't seen
this before it looks kind of ridiculous
but it's really interesting if you dig
into it yeah you know what eric i
actually um
it's funny the first time i came across
hey what do i do against d4
i actually watched your video on
the budapest gambit oh yeah
but you know you have a youtube video
where it it goes down that 10 move
line where white gets mated um
with yeah you probably just show that
real quick for people who maybe haven't
seen this before
i assume you're referring to this one
yeah
but um i realized uh i just
i guess maybe i didn't study it enough
and i wasn't
i think i just didn't study it enough
and i wasn't prepared for the other
lines i think yeah
i quickly just i think i just stopped
playing it so
gotcha but i did give this a shot yeah
but this is very nice
so with any yeah so like maybe maybe we
we won't have to like
go back to budapest if uh
if you've already tried it and it didn't
work but with any opening you choose
like there's always going to be some
early discomforts especially when you're
just playing new types of positions
and it's important if you are like
changing repertoire that you stick with
the lines for some extended period of
time
um regardless of what you choose and
rather than
uh
like giving up a line too soon try and
go back and and find where the
improvements are
um
of course one of the drawbacks of
budapest 2 is white can avoid it by
playing knife three first
and then
then you don't have e5 and white can
still transpose into more queens gambit
types of positions or d4 main lines
um
so
going back i guess going back to this
position okay budapest is still
it's still an opening dear to my heart
um
another approach is a knight's tango
which is knight c6
which is weirdly similar to the budapest
but it's not really a gambit
it's more like a
an offbeat strategic opening that can
still lead to
interesting types of attacking positions
and the idea
is to play an early e5
um
so if white plays like very natural move
knight c3 you play e5 and this time the
pawns support it like if white takes you
take black's doing completely fine here
you didn't have to commit anything
um if black plays or if white plays d5
then
you can get a structure which
um
i guess in some sense could resemble
like a king's indian
uh and i know you mentioned you played
kingzini at some point
um but it's actually a more pleasant
king's indian because your knight will
come
directly to the king side
your bishop will develop outside
this eventual pawn chain
let me just play a few moves let's say
knight f3 here
um here here here
uh this is ideal setup which you can get
from a lot of like night tango positions
um where then later in the middle game
you're in very good shape to attack
on the king side very low risk very
strategic it can be uh
enjoyable to play if you can at least
achieve the this early structure
with pawn on d5 and
your pawn and e5 and d6
actually
so
i'm just trying to give you like a
a taste of of different options and then
um
and then maybe you can choose like
what sort of
uh this a weird comparison but like what
sort of entree you want if you want the
fish the chicken everything should be
edible it's just kind of the flavor
a position that you want
yeah that that sounds awesome eric i i
appreciate that this yeah this night's
tango
is
is definitely um
i've never yeah i don't think i've i've
i've played i definitely haven't played
it and uh
i think uh it seems interesting it's
less renown yeah i've i played it once
like the first time i really looked into
it i played it in like a serious over
the board game
um against rochelle wu who maybe you
know the player
um
just as a surprise opening and it worked
out really nicely i got very dynamic
position
uh she she also went into this exact
line
um
the thing is if you play knight's tango
there's a few other things you kind of
have to be prepared for
um of course d5 looks like very natural
for white just to kick the knight
um yeah i was going to ask about that
actually on
i'm checking three yeah i'm checking the
stats so d5 is the third most played
move
okay most common is knight f3
or knight c3 followed by knight f3
um if white plays g5
i think from a objective point of view
this is not such a great move because
after 95 white's a bit overextended and
you're ready to play
e6 on the very next move
um
if white plays a move like bishop f4 to
try and get tempo on your knights
you just retreat and get tempo on the
bishop
ah okay um
a move like knight f3
of course developing with tempo you
could even grab the pawn here on c4 so
white has to be careful like they leave
anything hanging
um
let's say they play e3 just defending e3
is most common defending the pawn
then then you play e6
and like you're already pressuring the
center you have more development than
white
uh bishop b4 is coming very soon
castling
um
and there's been there's been a few
thousand games from this position black
scores
reasonably well where you're getting
something a bit more offbeats compared
to the
some more standard lines
actually
um
so of course like we can dig into these
lines more
um
but going back to this position
i think the most annoying move to meet
as a knights tango player
is knight f3
because then you can play e5
and you have to kind of mix up your
your plans a bit
um actually maybe you could still play
e5 and transpose to a budapest
but
the move i would recommend here is e6
and then
okay then the the plan is actually very
simple and you actually could transpose
into
what will resemble a nimzo indian
uh where you put your bishop on b4 you
prioritize just quick development of
your pieces uh you'll castle very
quickly
and the general plan is to go for a
setup with d6 and eventually e5
i see so there's a lot of ways this can
branch out but as long as you know kind
of the
the arrows that i've drawn maybe in
conjunction with queen e7
it's hard to go wrong as black
um i see and then the bishop the light
squared bishop will
just
usually come out last
but it stays on this diagonal
okay and yeah the reason why you put
your pawns up like this not only to
fight for the center but to give your
bishop some life later on
yeah
um
so white will play this or this but
regardless of what white does you you
play bishop b4 castle
um
when the knight's on c3 at some point
you usually like to take it
essentially damage the structure
um
and there's so many ways a position can
branch out but as long as you have a
clear plan
going into the middle game it's uh it's
hard to go wrong
let me actually make a new chapter i
should have been making new chapters uh
oh
initially but
the line i want to show you is cambridge
springs
oh okay which have you heard of before
maybe you've seen it in one of my videos
um i hadn't i hadn't heard of it before
before you you uh mentioned it yeah okay
i know i mentioned it to you in dm
um but the point is you you start with
the queen's gap decline like very solid
opening
um
not anything like super out of the
ordinary
and the point is to play a setup
or you can start with c6 or knight t7
um knight d7 is actually trickier here
and uh there's a trap
if white takes a pawn
that looks free on d5
black to move and punish white
the first move that come
first move that came to mind was bishop
b4 but that just hangs the bishop that's
one way to lose more material
um
[Music]
i don't think i see it eric
okay uh i'll go ahead and show you
actually no i'll give you a clue
my shirt is a clue you have to give away
your most valuable oh
oh my goodness really yes
what
wait there's only one queen move
queen e7
oh yeah there there is only one queen
move but you're not gonna
you're not gonna do that to your queen
there's another way to give away your
queen
okay um
yeah this is so bad i don't see it
uh
well you see your your thing your knight
is pinned right
okay
so just i guess just taking the knight
yeah
and the point you lose your queen
but it's only temporary
because after bishop takes g8
let's continue
oh my goodness i don't
uh
oh yeah i guess bishop bishop before
before
okay white has one legal move to block
with a queen
you take
and
yeah this is this can be mind-blowing if
you haven't seen this before geez um
it's a nice little opening trap which
thousands of people have fallen into
on the chest
um
definitely not
moves i i would have considered wow
that's very it's very nice yeah it's a
bit unnatural like to start by like
blocking in your your queen and leaving
your pawn
uh seemingly hanging but uh
yeah
6600 people have fallen into this and
counting wow
um yeah so the move knight b to d7
i
that i don't know what it is maybe it's
just the type of player i am i owe
i tend to always just obey like
certain principles like not
you know trying to not block
like when i see that move
it seems unnatural because i'm i'm
limiting the mobility of my
of my light squared bishop
so i i tend to not i i tend to not stray
towards away from
away from like
basic principles but this is um
i guess in order to to play certain
lines that interest more interesting
lines that's um
that's what you have yeah sometimes you
break principles i mean another like
another point with knight d7 is that
there's cases where your bishop just
fiend ketos
yeah you temporary block it but it will
find a home eventually
okay and that's actually one of the like
one of the main lines if you wanted to
play something like really solid against
the queen's gambit
and you didn't want to study too much
you can stick with this setup based
opening where you
you can play this against pretty much
everything just castle b6 bishop b7 and
c5
and this was this is what i did for
a good portion of like my early
chess career
like in my childhood i just kind of
played this and
got by for the most part and had
reasonable positions because
black has nice nice piece harmony
and
um
like very very solid setup and then it's
just a fight in the middle game
i see
so
let me uh
let me actually title this this is
called
what is this called
wechat is calling it the orthodox
defense baffen variation
um we'll just call it the qgd
um standard
queensland declines
um
which is not the cambridge springs
oh it's not oh it's not
we're getting to that
so cambridge springs is when
you're not going to fee encounter the
bishop
it's a position okay white's going to
play the two most natural moves knight
of 3 and e3
you're going to play c6
really making your bishop sad
but
enabling a very aggressive move queen a5
[Music]
and this is the starting position of the
cambridge springs
white put all the pieces on their most
natural squares especially for queen's
gambit player
and what you're doing is
trying to
punish the placement
first of all of the king
secondly of the bishop
and maximize the amount of pressure
where black looks to follow through with
bishop b4 and also knight e4
i see
yeah i was about to ask why
i can see that putting the queen out
there on a5 is aggressive but i
i wasn't quite seeing immediately the um
the follow-ups but but yeah i see yeah
yeah
this is the only uh only the starts like
we're only scraping the surface
oh okay i'll show you one example it's
like that if you're gonna learn the
cambridge springs it's like the first
thing you learn
is what happens when white plays like
the most natural looking developing move
bishop d3
and
if i were cruel
i would give this position to you and
and have you find the best move
but i'm not too cruel i'm going to give
you one
i'm going to give you the first move but
i'll have you find the second move
okay thank you only being slightly cruel
so you're in the tape
okay
white will take back and now it's up to
you to find the continuation of your
black
um
i don't think i want to give you any
clues just find find the move that
you think is best here sure
sure um
the moves that jump out at me are
i mean
knight e4
i think you did mention earlier
bishop b4 um
94
puts
pressure on
the bishop on g5 since there's
there's two attackers at that point um
and oh maybe i should use arrows as well
yeah
i guess you could draw yours too
yeah um
i know i guess maybe i should think some
more but i think yeah though i think
those are
those are probably the moves that i
would
so if you had to choose between 94 and
bishop b4
which move is more powerful
i see
i would have to say 94 just because you
know
your problem you're also
putting pressure on this knight um
you're putting double pressure on the
knight as well as the bishop so yep yeah
knight e4 is just a fork
you have uh
you have a double attack
the queen and the knight
attack two things which are only
defended by one thing
so you're actually guaranteed to win
material here
i see wow and this is yet another
opening trap where uh over 3 000 players
have walked into this position
um
and a good number of the players like as
white don't realize their bishop is
hanging
they play queen c2 and they just lose a
bishop
ah
that's what he takes takes
it's so hard to see yeah
um
so it's nice thing about cambridge
springs is you can
you can win material early against a lot
of like unprepared players
um of course the best line for white is
to save the bishop
play something like bishop f4
uh but then you win the pawn take
take take
almost winning the bishop on c4
white has knight d2
but then you can play bishop b4 keep the
pressure
threatening to take
here it kind of snowballs in black's
favor
wow
very nice
yeah i remember uh like learning this
opening when i was
a pretty young kid
and also like being kind of mind blown
with the
extent to
the traps uh that this can offer
i see this is this is kind of just a
random question that
does i'm just curious do you know the
origin of this the name of this
cambridge
i actually don't know
okay about wikipedia
so
the first recorded use of cambridge
springs was emmanuel alaska in 1892
[Music]
okay and he played it
oh so the name comes from
a 1904 tournament
in cambridge springs pennsylvania
oh nice
uh so it might be one of the only
chess openings named after an american
city
oh
that's true
trying to think of other i think there's
a chicago variation of the smith mora
the other thing i think we should have a
chapter devoted to
um is fighting
a london
which i think like at least probably
half the games you encounter d4 will
probably feature a london opening
um and london can start with
as i've said before either bishop f4 on
move two or knight f3 on move two
so let's say you're playing knife six
um
one can kind of choose the move order
and bishop f4 is like them i guess more
classical which people are playing these
days
and
i did look up your games in opening tree
i saw you play like a really cool
system against london
um
so
yeah i mean sometimes i try this just
because i
depending on the opponent's rating i'll
try this you know i'll try
the this opening i guess just like g5
like the opening trap yeah
yeah with g5 so just a show for a chat
g5 takes and queen a5 check
which i think you've had in like half
your games when you reach this position
which is kind of impressive yeah
yeah if the opponent's rating is perhaps
similar to mine then i
i sometimes i give it a shot
[Music]
yeah but i feel like that's not good
right i shouldn't just
it's a little bit dubious like it's
definitely
on the edge and
if you
if you want like a more
[Music]
straightforward
uh
i guess more respected approach
i can recommend
the setup just starting with d5
okay going for c5
knight c6 and queen b6
okay is what i really enjoy playing
i saw like you had some games um
maybe stemming from a different move
order where you take on d4 first
but one of the keys is to leave the
tension you're never
almost never afraid of white takes
because it it concedes the center pawn
there's usually many ways to win it back
most of the time light will like play
this sort of triangle formation
and you still leave the tension
and you strike with queen b6 hitting the
b2 pawn
which is one of the main targets in the
london because the bishop
has developed early to f4
and uh
like if you remember how to get to this
position this is
already um
i guess like half
half of what you need to know
um
here things can branch out a little bit
most players will play queen b3
yeah and then you're very happy to play
c4
gaining space
this is the move i always miss i think
yeah it's one of the reasons why you
don't take so early because you you
wanna
uh provoke white to either trade queens
after which you get a nice half open a
file
you have potential for the kind of queen
side pawn storm
and you'll you'll develop your pieces
very naturally
or white will retreat
and then you can play bishop f5 really
nice move
hitting the queen
uh if queen takes you win material
because the rook is trapped
i see wow and uh it's a nice bit of
opening preparation
most people play queen c1
and then you play e6 and
like black's already for choice here
nice pawn structure
more active pieces more space on the
queen side um
going forward from here i'll just show a
little bit more because
um
there's some players some players get to
this position and just don't know what
to do like they'll play bishop e7
they'll castle and then they'll just
start thinking in the middle game
um
there's a nicer plan
of playing queen
it's in this position
yeah you can play it here queen d8
um idea to develop the bishop to d6
challenging
a dark sport bishop for whites i know it
looks weird like undeveloping your queen
but it did its job on b6 and you're also
making way for this pawn storm b5 a5 b4
wow i see okay in general if you have
like a
a central pawn chain
you want to play on the side the pawn
chain is pointing towards
so if it's pointing towards the queen
side
it means you have more space on the
queen side you should be focusing on the
queen side in the middle game
okay yeah eric i think
i think we had a question and maybe i
had the same
[Music]
but i think you probably answered it
with that with that last statement but
the c pawn
is it in any way overextend it's not in
any way overextended because we're going
to be
storming on the queen side right yeah
it's it's well reinforced here um
it's a fair question because i guess
when you play c4
uh it's not too typical to like push
pawns into your opponent's territory
early on
but in this case it's justified no
matter what white does
um because
if we go back to
this position
um you're able to reinforce it so it's
way more of a strength than a liability
i see
and if white tries to chip away
this is a so-called chiseling move
and try and get rid of your overextended
pawn
in this case i'm pretty sure you can
just play b5
uh reinforcing and sometimes light will
try and chisel further
and really try and get rid of your pawns
but you have everything supported
wow okay it's actually nice your queen
defends the rook so if takes
takes you're maintaining your space's
advantage
you're okay with a rough trade
um
and you're kind of keeping this this
subtle advantage on the queen side
i see eric can i ask a question here so
when you were talking about chiseling
away at this um
do you would you say that you always
respond that
in what cases do you always
in what cases do you respond
by defending i guess
again against um yeah so
it's a very fair question um
and sometimes it does just depend on the
position
in this case because you have
you have enough defensive resources to
combat white's attacking resources
just enough like if if white had a move
somehow to apply more pressure or if
your bishop was still on c8 there'd be
this pin and that would be annoying
but your
usually comes down to like
if if you're properly developed which
you are in this position then there's
really nothing to worry about your
pieces are in good squares
and white's a bit more passive
um
i could show you another example
where
i made a new chapter called chiseling
where
if white
if we look look at let's say the slav
opening
you don't need to know about this lab
this is just uh instructional like
positional example
let's imagine white plays c5 immediately
and when i was first starting chess i
thought oh this looks like a good move
like you gain space you
lock down the queen side
but this is an example of
when white should not overextend
because now this chiseling actually
works
e6
white either has to take after which
like white just lost a lot of time
trading off this pawn
helping strengthen black's position
um and if white tries to reinforce
then a5 is very strong and white's not
going to be able to
actually effectively support the pawn
chain
if a3 you take and there's this pin
i see um
if white takes this way
she and every line pretty much white's
position kind of just falls apart here
white takes this way you take this way
and then
many cases black just wins upon
i see if white takes this way you take
this way again you're going to be
winning a pawn
so
this is one of these lessons i learned
like
i was 12 or 1300 but it made a
a lasting impact on
how i view like pawn structure and
um yeah kind of yeah that's really
helpful
yeah this is
i wish you're you're dropping so many
nice
profound morsels of wisdom i need to
i wish i could like write all this down
oh well it's being recorded for probably
the rest of yeah
yes people have been asking if this will
be on youtube
because twitch deletes a vod after like
a few weeks but
i don't want to immortalize this on
youtube
yeah i really this everything
everything that you're saying even just
you know
just i guess the um
[Music]
i don't know what to call them but just
like
just talking about the chiseling away
here
it that's really helpful to me because i
i don't it seems like a principle that i
should know but i i didn't really i
think
one last question on the the anti london
um sure do you
um
i saw on a youtube video
where
and when
is it wise to play a6
um
i guess like after queen b6
is it something that you play at all
so not in this specific line there might
be other lines where
okay
but
yeah not not in this line you you maybe
you saw in again mater's video
he had like a very specific video where
the knights
like there's actually a funny line i'll
show you where the knight comes in
and then
white wants to play this and hurt you
this is where actually a good number of
players will play a6 just to be extra
safe
um
in this line that i'm showing you like
a6 is usually not a typical idea like
even if like plays this move
there's a better move than a6
there's queen jigs b2
you
know
eric you know what this is this is kind
of this is what scares me
about
playing the london because i actually
usually play queen b6
but i never know when it's advent not
necessarily advantageous but when it's
safe to play
to play queen takes b2 queen gotcha too
i know you've been playing london in
different move orders where like you
play c5 and then very early queen musics
the move where i'm showing you is a bit
more sound where
like if white allows queen digs b2 it's
usually like really good for you um
this is one of the trickier lines though
where
after knight b5 you kind of have to know
what you're doing because white's
running this
you won't run into this too often though
like most players don't play knight e3
and if they do
you can play very nice move knight e4
and this is where you say oh no i'm
getting forked
and then white will fork you you'll lose
a rook
and now black to move
yeah i guess made on made on f2 yes
so i've had this exact game on me chess
uh
a handful of times
i think i saw you recently within the
last month or two play this actually
yeah um yeah
actually there's been 32 games total
that uh
i've wound up with enough to mate
so
it's uh it's a nice one to know and goes
to show
the
importance of just attacking in the
center
yeah thanks for showing that eric
yeah for sure um i guess the other thing
that came to mind that you just kind of
reminded me about
is joe bava london
where
a lot of people are doing the cj's is
playing knight
c3
yeah and then if you try and do the same
setup which i just showed you
then you have to be worried about knight
b5
and this is where you kind of have to
choose
a different path forward
like c5 and queen music still might be
playable but i wouldn't recommend it
um just because
when the knight commits to c3 so early
it's just a different sort of opening
and so
let me label this
london and we're going to make a new
chapter
interesting that's really great to know
eric because i
even if the opponent plays knight yeah
at the chobava i don't change what i do
oh necessarily
this is so important and this is a very
common mistake when people learn
openings
they'll learn like a specific setup and
they'll try and do that setup against
everything their opponent plays
yeah and uh if they're
if the opponent's doing something
slightly different
you might just get crushed if you do the
same thing that you
always try and do
um yeah actually so you just have to
treat this as another
basically another opening
um
and i
i could
offer a6 as a suggestion
but um
the the move i would recommend it might
be slightly weird looking at first is to
play e6
willingly blocking in your bishop
just to accelerate your kingside
development
hmm
[Music]
because most players
first of all most players will play e3
here just continue developing
right um
if white plays knight b5
uh
yeah white's attacking the pawn you you
have ways to defend you can play either
bishop d6
or um i recommend is knight a6
even though it looks weird like
you're ready to play c6 kick away this
night and white is losing time
and then later like bishop g6 and castle
and you're gonna have a small lead in
development
okay um
well the void plays e3
then
you can
develop with bishop to b4
and
it's a different development scheme but
the point is you're you're looking to
play c5
knight e4 queen a5
kind of in the style of cambridge
springs you put a lot of pressure on the
queen side from early on
and a lot of players could potentially
crumble here
um if we look at like a natural move
knights to f3
all of a sudden knight e4
and white's under
a lot of pressure like how to defend the
knights on c3
yeah i see well it can't play queen d2
they could play queen d3
but then c5
and now
you actually have a threat i'll test you
here let's say a3
black to move and punish white
i was thinking c4 immediately that's the
first move that came to mind um good
instinct
yeah this is another case where
uh over extending is justified
that's not really overextending you're
just attacking light and
you're removing the queen from defending
c3
so wherever the queen moves
you can
actually it's an interesting decision
here if you take with knight or bishop
both moves are winning
sticking with bishop is simple they take
take
and uh
yeah you win a pawn
i see
if knight takes you have to be
prepared for queen d2
which is a bit weird
actually
and then okay you can still move back
and get a
a better position but
i think this is simpler you win a clean
pawn you keep your initiative
life is very good
i see
uh eric back
if we could go back to
this
so after c5 here
what is oh let's just say white plays
the best move
sure
is pawn takes e5
okay
i just want to see what would be the
line after that um
just to see but um oh yeah of course
because okay obviously like stop your
thread of c4
um here you can continue just applying
pressure one of the other ideas of
playing c5 was to make your way for your
queen
right and now you have one two three
attackers on c3
white only has two defenders
and
there's not really a way to add a third
defender
wow
yeah i mean just looking at the um
the database it looks like black yes
black scoring yeah black square as well
um now there is queen b5 check which
uh would force a queen trade
but you're still in like really really
good shape
actually not sure like i guess you could
play knight t6
and after the queen trade
uh white's still like this pin is so
annoying
yeah i see white doesn't have a way to
defend c3
okay yeah thanks for showing that
yep sure thing so i know we went into
kind of some
deeper lines there but uh
again the point is to kind of give you a
taste of how things can branch out how
you react to different moves like can
play
um
i think do you want to move on to like
playing games where
yeah
i can i can try to play oh and i guess
when people challenge you they should be
challenging you
and playing d4
because we want to practice like our d4
repertoire so hopefully most people know
that
that's right okay
so i have a game here um
i've started a game here this is casual
great
yeah
okay
okay i'm kind of scared eric i'm gonna
try my best yeah don't be afraid
okay
oh it's london time okay london how much
okay remember what i just showed you
mentioned oh oops okay computers lagging
okay so d5 okay
let's start usually i've i have been
playing c5 but now i'm switching things
up so
now i'll proceed with c5 i believe yeah
c5 it's i guess one move delayed but
very similar ideas
okay
okay
i think knight c6
seems good to me
looking good i'm just actually i'm just
i guess just what you mentioned against
the london
yeah actually that hangs
just that hangs the pawn but that's okay
right that's okay that's completely okay
like you're you're basically playing a
reverse queen's gambit
where if white were to take the pawn you
you'd win it back in a variety of ways
right um yeah oh eric so you know what
this position
really confuses me a lot of the time
when there's pawns attacking pawns
yeah because i i encounter you counter
the situation but
i always analyze my games and it from
what from
maybe it's just me but i always remember
stockfish saying take
like
a different plot
okay so i'm gonna give you a rule
whenever there is like this this pawn
cube but pawn like two pawns attacking
each other adjacently
you're almost always supposed to take
one of the pawns
the way you figure out which pawn to
take
is um
in this case
white wants to develop the lights right
bishop right
so if you take on c4
white just takes back and develops a
bishop you don't want to help white
develop right right so by process of
elimination if you're not taking on c4
what to do okay
so
so you mentioned yeah you i've noticed
that you always want to take one at
least when this occurs so i'm just going
to take on d4
good
okay and there's other reasons to take
on d4
um
going back to yeah go go ahead
so you said you it's always best to take
when this
cube occurs is there
some
underlying reason for that
so there's never a time where um never
say never there's exceptions but in
general
um
and like the reason for that is like
usually
[Music]
ah it's hard to explain
like usually if you give the option to
your opponent it will benefit them to
take either way
um okay in this case also like you're
trading you traded the c pawn for
the d-pawn so you like now you have more
center pawns than white because you have
e and d against d so it's like slightly
beneficial
i see okay
the other thing is that imagine
these d and c pawns get traded white
will be left with an isolated queen's
pawn
which is just a probably beneficial
structure for you
i see okay
now here you have options um
feel free to like talk through what you
want to do
[Music]
you're okay uh
or just well whatever candid moves you
have
okay i guess the the the move we
you mentioned is just queen b6 probably
here but um
that's what i'm thinking maybe queen b6
or
94
maybe too early for knight e4 uh
i think i'll play queen b6 at this point
queen b6 is is i think a fine move
um
this is slightly different than the
other position because the center is
more open
um
the other thing you should consider
doing is completing development
i know like i talked about queen b6
earlier but that was other line like
your bishops should really
develop at some points
i see um so maybe e6
so you could play pawn e6
queen v6 is still a candid move because
you're attacking b2 so you you have some
uh
initiative with that
you could also like develop your light
squared bishop like bishop f5 or g4
um
and then after you play e6 your bishop's
more active
so
i'm going to leave it up to you
okay choose between queen b6 e6
developing your bishop
these are the moves that uh i think are
most logical
okay yeah typically i would get my
bishop out
try to get my [ __ ] about so i'll play
yeah i'll play bishop f5 sure very
respectable
and yeah i know you mentioned knight e4
but this is a move that should come
later like in the middle game
after you've complete development
actually got your king safe
okay
um
yeah i mean at this point
at this point again i'm eyeing the
opponent might be eyeing um
[Music]
knight b5 but
maybe i could still
i can still just go queen b6 here
or am i thinking like queen a5
that's more towards like the cambridge
springs
yeah either queen a5 um
you don't want to overthink this of
course white white's putting more
pressure on d5
so you you can continue with your
original plan of just playing e6 and
being solid
uh or if you want to play queen a5 i
think that that's a useful square for
the queen
um
if white ever plays knight b5 you have
rook c8 so
i'm just not in trouble yeah maybe i
should just be looking trying to play
the game i'm being set up on
uh
yeah of course you have to move quicker
too given the time situation yeah
yep okay i'll play e6
i know we've been like talking about
these these opening situations in like a
lot of detail but it is burning time um
which is just another thing we uh have
to focus on so
i think e6 it requires
at least it sets you up for
very simple next moves
like you're going to develop your bishop
somewhere b4 d6
e7
and then castle
and you'll have a very solid position
the middle game is going to be a fight
but uh
you're getting out of the opening with
no
no worries
okay yeah this this struck this position
seems pretty
seems pretty solid to me
i feel comfortable i guess
yeah and like of course it kind of
strayed away very early from what we had
covered initially and this is
kind of expected when it comes to
openings opponents will
play unexpected things
okay so
[Music]
your b7 pawn is attacked
okay
um
oh man
let me ask you is there a way to develop
your bishop and defend b7 simultaneously
uh
yeah i guess bishop b4 yeah
it's just like the most multi-purpose
move there were other moves too but
given the time situation okay
um
this is what you want to accomplish you
want to get your king safe
and if white leaves the king in the
center for too long
then then you might have time to
actually
punish white
i see
yeah thanks for uh
thanks for walking through the logic
with me eric um yeah keep going
okay i would probably just castle here
looks good
is that is that
is there an opportu i would probably
just castle yeah completely fine wasn't
that two okay yeah
like there are certain things that you
just don't want to overthink like okay
there are options there's still this
pawn tension
between d5 and c4
but uh yeah you're completing
development
yeah
oh you so eric i have a can i ask you a
question here yeah go for it
when
i get in these positions and all my
pieces are relatively developed
obviously my queen is still
on the back rank um
[Music]
let me play a move here
yeah exactly so when i get to these
positions i don't
really know what to do all right
this is very common yeah
and i think about improving
yeah i'll just
make this move for now okay
um i mean of course like in these middle
game positions you like you want to
bring your rooks in
usually you want to put your rooks
either on open files or half open files
or files which might become open
in the near future
so
yeah 27
37 is playable there was rook c8 which
maybe would have been a bit more
flexible
okay
um
there's also the
like at some point you might want to
take on c4
and then actually give white iso pawn
and then you take away the option of
white
essentially playing c5
i see so take
take on c4
and then
white would either have to shoot with
bishop or queen
okay
but then like when you take on c4 then
d4 becomes more of a target
um actually
oh okay so queen a4 so there's some
alignment
between the queens
yeah
uh
any moves that come to mind here
i mean i guess
moving my knight away but then that
at the end of that i don't know if i'm
[Music]
is it just even or am i winning a pawn
maybe
or do i take on c3
first
you could take on c3 first that removes
the defender of the white queen
yeah mm-hmm
um i think
i'll i'll just should i i just
yeah that's that's fine and the reason
to do this is actually it's purely
tactical
in general you don't want to make this
trade like which helps strengthen white
center
but assuming white takes back
now you have a really cool tactical idea
exploiting the fact white's queen is
undefended
yeah um you see it i'm trying to see it
i mean the first move that comes to my
mind is just taking the pawn
which one with the knight
and then i have a possibility of taking
the knight on f3 with check check right
if i need to um
i guess i'll
i guess i'll try that
yeah i i know maybe you don't seem you
don't sound so confident but uh now take
your time here because there's a few
candidate moves
of course you can take the knight with
check but what else can you do
yeah i see the bishop on e2
um
i also called the check i guess
yeah up a piece i guess right
uh oh your opponent's being so generous
adding time and and you won free
material
wow
yeah okay okay
and now you you win back the queen
that's the power of the well the inter
meso in between move
very nice yeah thank you for guiding me
in that
it's the type of thing like if you do
regular tactics training you'll you'll
see more quickly and you'll be more
confident in
i see um
now i feel like i should stop guiding
you and you should you should just
get the job done
okay i'm just gonna move my rook
oh though this kind of blocks my other
rook
was that um was that maybe
[Music]
i think i have moved it yeah there were
other options it wasn't a big decision
like you're up a piece as long as you're
not like blundering anything
um
and honestly i probably would have
played the same move because you put
immediate pressure on white sea pawns
you might even be winning another pawn
here
because if the trade happens on d5
at the end you're gonna be hitting c3
okay so white's going for
counter-attack okay
um i guess that just hank that hung the
um
very good rook i almost didn't see that
wow i almost just i was about to play b6
yeah b6 would have been the ultra safe
move but
your opponent gives you free stuff you
take it
okay like it's still very early in the
game but uh
like so far all you've done is like
capitalize on on white's i guess
blunders
versus the tactical sequence was key
with uh knight d4
now of course white could take back the
bishop
i can just
sit and cry
okay i guess i'll
want to take a pawn but maybe i'll just
play b6 first
just like the knight the knight is
undefended as well so
yeah yeah you didn't want to give white
any unnecessary counter play and uh
and this at least one of the c pawns
should fall eventually
um for the sake of time should we
continue this game or
um if the opponent wants to continue um
obviously we're
uh we're beyond the opening i feel like
there are already a lot of good lessons
um
should also note like this is casual
rated so
if if we wanted to cut it short and play
another game uh
that's that's fine but
uh i guess i'll just ask if that's okay
is that is that okay ross the boss um
just because i uh
i know you know we always say never
resign because there eric says that but
okay
there's always exceptions to the rules
all right okay so c4 was like the the
first kind of surprise move which
um
led to a lot of good lessons the first
being like of course
you should take take one of the pawns
um before
proceeding with development
um as a review if c3
you would have played queen b6 and this
would have been
more uh
more following what i showed you
right before the game
um
now going forward
yeah there are a lot of options i was
actually like curious what the best
approach is
uh you played bishop f5
i think bishop g4 is even more
venomous
because you pin the knight and you
you're really trying to exploit this
pawn on d4
oh eric can i ask another sorry i'm
asking so many questions um yeah you
don't have to ask if you can ask a
question
okay
all right
so
this really this is real this really
gets me i know this gets talked about a
lot um
when do you want to pin the knight as
opposed to not pinning the knight
for example i went to bishop f5 um to me
this seems like black white can just
easily
guard
guard the knight with bishop e2 right
so that that's kind of my thinking i
know this is yeah commonly talked
discussed but i still
so in this case
it's strong
so in this case um
yeah of course it always depends like i
guess bishop f5 it's a more centralized
square
and it won't immediately like be
challenged with h3 or bishop e2
but the reason to play bishop g4 here
is that this bishop is already doing
another job in supporting c4
also you're playing bishop g4 not only
with idea of playing the knights
but pressuring this pawn more because in
some cases you just want to take the
knight and then win the d4 pawn
got it yeah that's right that's right so
bishop e2
then
[Music]
there's a few options here like you
could you could continue and um pressure
later or you can just win a pawn
right away
given that uh the bishop's a bit
overworked
um
this could get messy but it should be in
black's favor just given
you have a lot of
pieces just well placed in the center
and d4 should
should be falling like bishop takes c4 i
think you just take on f3 and
you're keeping initiative the whole time
too
and f3 you keep making threats
um so the play flows very nicely
yeah that's so crazy how that flows from
a seemingly common move where you're
you're pinning the knight there's so
many opportunities
yeah yeah if we see like a slow motion
replay
every single move you made in the
sequence starting with c takes d4
is either a threat or a capture
you capture the pawn
you when you pin the knight you're
making the threat of taking
and taking so like defended you make a
capture
another capture and then you win
material
and keep making sense
so i see wow yeah initiative is a very
powerful concept in chess
and usually applies when you get like
the the early leading development
or you can like develop while attacking
stuff
um and this is a nice example of it
i see eric so when you're playing your
game when you're playing
you are you always thinking about you're
always thinking about initiative on
every single move is that right it's one
of the first things that comes to mind
like
of course depending on the position like
some positions it's hard to make threats
we have to be a bit more patient or
strategic
but um
if you've ever
watched like these instructed videos
from gotham chess
there's one thing that he preaches like
many of the times is
checks captures attacks
right this is a way to generate
initiative
where if you can play a sequence of
checks captures attacks you can
very often
either like make big improvements to
your position or win material with some
like tactical sequence
um right right
so it's always something like you should
at least
check first to see if you have moves to
seize initiative and then if you don't
then you want to look for
more uh
more strategic moves which either make
improvements or have some like plan in
mind whether it be
like improving your worst place peace or
pressuring one of your opponent's
weaknesses
or sometimes just defending
opponents threats like there's different
things you can
ask yourself what to do
yeah i see i think when i um
i've i always have that in mind when i'm
doing puzzles obviously
but i i realize i don't
i don't always have that mindset when i
play my games
so i think i need to try to adopt that
more
yeah
and like sometimes puzzles like there's
one clear solution where obviously you
want to be winning material somehow or
mating
but in chess it's not always like so
clear-cut
where like bishop g4 it's not really a
puzzle type thing but it's the most
active move to
put white under the most pressure so
yeah very often moves like this can
later lead to like puzzle type
situations where you can
eventually win material
um like in order to generate tactics
your your pieces need to be on good
squares
right i see
yeah thanks eric yeah
and i think what happened in the game
like you you got your pieces of good
squares and then white actually
just fell victim
given there were
there were different targets in the
position
and
i know i kind of helped with this of
course the game was unrated so
no rating points were lost the cost of
your opponent but uh it's very nice idea
to first
remove the defender of the queen
and then yeah proceed with this it's a
pretty aesthetic tactical sequence
yeah
it's very nice so eric the that removing
the defender that was the move you would
is that what the move
is that was that the right move or yeah
bishop takes c3 was i think maybe the
only way to
win material by force
okay
because
if you take first on d4
there's a few problems with this of
course like the queen's still defended
so white could take back and you just
lost a piece
um okay actually but when we
when we remove the knight then we're
setting up this uh
nice little
knight takes g4 with in between move
so nice pattern okay
and then
yeah
now it's a pretty quick game uh yeah at
least in terms of number of moves but
we got some good lessons from it
yeah definitely thanks so much it was
really yeah this is a great instructive
game
i hope uh hope you got some value from
this hope people
watching got value from this if this
goes on youtube shout out to youtube
people
[Music]
yeah thanks so much for your twitter in
the future youtube description
and in the twitter chat too
thanks so much
hey how about a big cheers to eric
oh let's go
thanks david
wait wait cheers there wait
i have the same mug
oh nice uh i need to wash it but uh all
right treat every blunder as a gambit
yeah
let's go